[Music]
Frankfurt Airport is one of Europe's
most important air traffic hubs every
day it handles almost 1300 takeoffs and
landings and more than 165 thousand
passengers
all the airborne and earthbound
operations have to function absolutely
smoothly to keep the rapid succession of
takeoffs and landings on schedule
[Music]
that's a mammoth task even when the
weather is good imagine the challenge
when ice and snow cover the runways if
just 10 centimeters of snow fall on the
ramps taxiways and runways then about
six thousand truckloads of snow have to
be removed
[Music]
this is what a fast cost-effective
solution could look like Mercedes new
remote truck interface system
coordinates vehicles on closed company
sites to operate as automated convoys
[Applause]
Yamaha mafia here are 4 automated Iraq
trucks as Phillip Dreyer of Daimler's
lab 1886 they been automated for
removing snow from the airport runways
they are remote control and a
differential GPS system locates them on
the airfield that means that in addition
to the normal GPS system familiar from
navigation devices there is a local
correction system up on the tower of the
testing grounds it refines the GPS
reading so that the snow removal trucks
are steered within a tolerance of
centimetres remote truck interface is a
step toward a completely networked and
autonomous utility vehicle the system
was developed in collaboration with
specialists from the company that
operates Frankfurt Airport no special
sensors are involved they wouldn't work
in bad weather anyway communication
between the vehicles and the operators
is by encoded radio signal
[Music]
[Music]
listen Philip dryer explains that the
automation of these snow removal trucks
has two aspects first they drive
themselves acceleration braking and
steering are carried out with a central
control unit second another central unit
controls the snow removal equipment it's
operated by a person in the lead vehicle
what's new here is that the operator and
the lead vehicle is not a driver there's
no need to steer a break
allowing closer supervision of the
convoys operations in kind father is
sananda baba cotton knew or didn't
believe this convoys as a length neat
offense nissan navara box-and-one snow
removal at Frankfurt Airport cost 23
million euros last winter the weather
services snow predictions often turn out
to be false alarms the advantages of the
remote truck interface system are rapid
and flexible use of the vehicles and
high precision this system could be
useful also on construction sites when
clearing minefields and ocean harbors
and in agriculture the system works only
on closed grounds but has proved to be
very reliable all that still lacking is
a test under severe snow conditions
[Music]